show me something draft week 10. i'm in
a good mood today so i'm going to let
you have the first pick i'd even let you
have the first pick if i was in a bad
mood you get the first pick
show me something donovan donovan smith
and tristan worfs
last week the offensive line of the
tampa bay buccaneers look they know that
brady is not going to be able to move a
lot and get out of a lot of trouble
but they allowed
tom brady to get the crap beat out of
him last week period
and uh you know the chief perpetrators
in my mind when i'm watching the game
are the right tackle tristan worfs and
the left tackle donovan smith play
better keep your quarterback alive
show me something joe burrow this is the
moment you've been waiting for this is
your opportunity an undefeated steelers
team eight and oh they're a little
wobbly ben roethlisberger injured knees
and not at practice all week borrow an
incredible amount of confidence
an incredible amount of belief in the
guys around him no sacks last time they
played against the titans even though
they had 80 turnover on the offensive
line i just look i'm getting emails from
steelers fans saying you are trying to
will the steelers to lose why don't you
get on board with the idea that they go
16-0
watch the games they can't win every
game playing the way they've been
playing can they and if they're ever
going to be vulnerable it's in a game
like this when they let their guard down
a little bit and in come the bengals i
think the bengals can take it and this
is joe burrows opportunity on the day
when tua and justin herbert at the same
time when they are battling joe barro
can show to everyone i'm the guy out of
this class i slayed the giant and took
down the last remaining undefeated team
in the nfl
i love that because he can do it he
really can do it if they give him a
little bit of time and the quarterback
doesn't get killed uh and look the
steelers are great with the pass rush i
really like that one mike show me
something
baker mayfield okay you're entering the
la the second half
of your third pruvit season okay how
many more prove it opportunities are you
gonna have okay
this is a game you've got to win houston
at home foundering houston playing a
little bit better without bill o'brien
but still this is a game you absolutely
must have and look i want to see
consistency from baker mayfield down the
stretch i don't want to see up one week
down the next and that's what you've
seen too often with them show me some
consistency baker mayfield and show me a
dominating performance against a team
that you ought to be able to beat by
double digits
my next pick was one of your goats of
the week for week nine and i know you
did it reluctantly because he's a hell
of a story but alex smith show me
something you get a full week to prepare
for this game against the lions you
don't get thrust into the fray halfway
through because of kyle allen's latest
injury some of those plays last week
that didn't work out maybe not
necessarily alex smith's fault give him
the opportunity to get ready as he's
getting and let's see what he can do
peter on the almost two year anniversary
of that badly broken leg it would be
something to see alex smith and
washington take down the lions and alex
smith give the washington football team
reason to believe they can maybe sneak
up on everyone and take that division
show me something daniel jones you know
you've proven to all the world that you
can beat washington if the giants played
washington a thousand times they'd win
999
but you haven't shown you can beat
anybody else
so show me something in a game that you
were drafted to win
at home
big game
philadelphia eagles
a wounded philadelphia eagles team
this is a game daniel jones that you
were drafted to win show me something
i could take either quarterback for this
next one from the game where they're
going to be facing each other but i am
going to say show me something
justin herbert because justin you're the
guy the dolphins didn't want they took
tua not you you could have had you they
took tua and you've been pretty damn
good this year you've been better than
tua you've maybe been better than joe
burrow but here's the problem the team
around you justin herbert isn't good
enough between the coaching staff
between the defense between everyone but
you they keep finding ways to lose so
justin and i'm i have a reason for doing
this peter i've picked the chargers to
beat the dolphins on sunday justin
listen to me justin
you've got to do this you've got to be
the one to step up and build the
17-point lead and this time don't let it
go away keep it 17-24 make it 24 make it
31. i'm telling you this team is good
enough to go into miami and beat a
dolphins team that may be feeling
unjustifiably good about itself right
now peter and if justin herbert shows us
something he'll make me look like not an
idiot for picking the chargers to win
show me something again dalvin cook
and i say again because clearly you know
there's nobody in the last two weeks in
the entire league who's carried his team
the way dalvin cook has with the
minnesota vikings but it's a little bit
of a different animal this
this is the chicago bears defense this
is soldier field and this is the game
that the minnesota vikings in my opinion
have to win if they're going to convince
themselves
that they can make a wild card run and
make the playoffs now look mike dalvin
cook has been absolutely phenomenal 6.0
yards per carry obviously if he does
that for the year it's far and away an
nfl record for a single season
but he goes in to face the bears and
look the bears have been occasionally
um you know run at a bull
you know they're they're giving up four
yards of carry and so you they're not uh
peerless
um you know against the runs so to me
this is a game that i think the vikings
should have the exact same game plan
dalvin cook early and often alexander
madison in relief for eight or ten totes
this is the way the vikings have to play
football the rest of the way
i'll see your monday night and i'll
raise you a monday night i'm gonna say
show me something nick foles you know
the last time falls faced the vikings
similar circumstances home underdog were
the philadelphia eagles in the 2017 nfc
championship game no one believed that
nick foles and the eagles could beat the
vikings that day i'm stunned that the
vikings are two and a half point
favorites to win at soldier field a
place where they've lost four of the
last 19 times they've played there
especially because of that defense but
at some point nick foles has to make
that throw and if he can make a few
throws like the throws he made three
years ago
that's the thing that stops the bleeding
for a bears team that was five and one
cruising toward the post season and now
loss after loss after loss they're at
five and four and this one to me i'm not
going to say it's an elimination game
for the bears because we've seen five
and five teams pull it around but
usually it's a team that's ascending not
a team that's descending they lose this
one they very well may be done if they
can beat the vikings vikings go to three
and six they're probably done they'd
have to run the table or something close
to it to get to the postseason this is a
huge monday night game and it's time for
nick foles to go back to that mindset
that magic that special quality he
captured on that sunday late afternoon
in january of 2018 and do what he did
then and save the bears season peter
hey look foles is going to have an
opportunity you know because even though
i think minnesota's defense is rising
recently he's gonna have some chances to
be able to make plays
so i think the bears have a chance in
this game and that's why if i were
minnesota i'd be playing keep away not
because i fear the offense but because
there's something about nick foles that
if i'm mike zimmer i'm going to say look
i i don't i don't really love nick foles
you know he's not mahomes but man he
shows up in big games so i would not be
surprised if he showed up in this game
okay mike my final show me show me
something sean mcvay
the last time the los angeles rams were
on the field
they were essentially just totally uh
swept away by a miami defense that
people weren't really respecting
probably enough but where in the world
was that the the you know the front wall
of the los angeles rams so to me mcveigh
has got a figure away
this week against seattle where you
should be able to figure away keep jared
goff clean you're gonna have to score in
the 30s to beat russell wilson show me
something sean mcvay
peter you have perfected the art of
casually expanding the draft from three
rounds to four
by perfecting the art of casually
expanding the draft from four rounds to
five i didn't have any more but i'll say
this
show me something carson wentz because
brett favre thinks you stink you stink
he thinks that go out and show brett
favre that indeed you do not stink one
last note before we go to break peter
in this age of analytics everyone is
keeping track of high-level statistical
analysis and trends we have our own
sabermetrics department here at pft live
i'm told that in four of the last six
weeks that daniel jones has played on
any day but thursday you have picked him
in the show me something draft
[Laughter]
i want to see something out of him
all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports